madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20h
nous sommes prêts tout près de la
libération
c'est ce que viennent de déclarer les
autorités vénézuéliennes concernant les
trois otages en colombie
il y à quelques heures un responsable de
la mission humanitaire aurait même reçu
les fameuses coordonnées du lieu où les
otages doivent être récupérées jamais
l'espoir n'avait donc été aussi grand
que ce soir pour en parler avec nous
mais la nuit la fille d'ingrid
betancourt bonsoir merci est tout à
l'heure au pakistan dans la dynastie
buteau les partisans demande le fils
bilawal 19 ans vient d'être nommé
président du parti du peuple à la place
de sa mère assassinée il ya trois jours
et l'opposition affirme ce soir être en
mesure de participer aux élections
législatives prévues le 8 janvier la
rupture jusque dans les 24 heures avant
ceux de nicolas sarkozy nous avons
comparé ceux des précédents présidents
vous verrez que le style a évolué et ce
n'est pas fini c'est ce que promet
l'elysée pour demain soir autre
incontournable de fin d'année les
étrennes que reste-t-il de la tradition
à qui donner et combien c'est ce que
nous verrons dans ce journal
enfin 28 heures avant 2008 nous vous
offrirons une rétrospective de l'année
sportive écoulée
de la joie et des larmes les émotions
n'ont pas manqué cette année on commence
bien sûr avec l'espoir en colombie on
aurait presque envie ce soir de ne plus
parler au conditionnel tant la
libération promise des trois otages
semblent avancer mais avec la guérilla
des farc il faut rester prudent jusqu'au
bout il ya quelques heures un
responsable de la mission humanitaire
aurait reçu les coordonnées du lieu où
les otages doivent être récupérés dans
la jungle le et de la mort les deux
nouveaux hélicoptères plus petit c'est
cela qui devrait aller chercher les
otages ils arrivent du venezuela ceux
initialement prévu resteront au sol
les farc ont indiqué qu'ils étaient trop
gros pour se poser au lieu de
rendez-vous dans la jungle
les farc ont exigé le plus grand secret
le point de rencontre est perdu dans la
jungle dans une région grande comme les
deux tiers de la france jusqu'à la
dernière minute
les organisateurs sont restés prudents
je suis raisonnablement inquiet nous
voulons vraiment que cette opération
marché nous redoutons n'importe quel
embûches qui pourrait tout faire capoter
dans un entretien par téléphone le
président vénézuélien hugo chavez grand
instigateur de la mission a prévenu
qu'il faudrait peut-être trois ou quatre
jours supplémentaires
bonne surprise le gouvernement colombien
partisan de la manière forte a fait
preuve de souplesse et annoncé qu'il
pourrait prolonger l'autorisation de
survol de son territoire dans un hôtel
proche de l'aéroport
les familles attendent jamais elles
n'ont senti la libération des leurs
aussi proche
c'est un signe qui montre que les
relations entre chavez et le président
colombien uribe s'améliore qu'ils
acceptent de travailler ensemble pour
obtenir des résultats et je les félicite
pour cela
hugo chavez a souvent irrité la colombie
et les états unis le réalisateur
américain oliver stone est venu lui
apporter son soutien
l'amérique doit comprendre que le
venezuela n'est pas notre ennemi est
peut-être un allié je suis d'accord avec
notre candidat à la présidentielle
barack obama parle quand il dit que nous
devrions parler aux gens au lieu de les
combattre
si la libération des otages réussi ce
serait à coup sûr un succès diplomatique
pour le président vénézuélien
alors en attendant d'en savoir plus
soyons maintenant qu'ils sont ces trois
otages que la guérilla dit avoir accepté
de libérer sans contrepartie
parmi vous le savez il y à une proche
ingrid betancourt sa plus proche
collaboratrice même elles ont été
kidnappés ensemble il ya six ans
maintenant
hakim abdel khaleq elle est la
confidente l'ami la complice de toujours
depuis 15 ans clara roja c'est une
grille de bettencourt sont inséparables
elles travaillent ensemble au sénat puis
se lance en 2002 dans la course à la
présidentielle
elle sillonne les routes du pays clara
roja c'est la directrice de campagne de
la candidate franco colombienne le 23
février 2002 elles se rendent dans une
zone contrôlée par les farc
elles veulent prouver qu'elles peuvent
aller partout et parler à tout le monde
mais de femmes sont prises en otages
quelques heures plus tard les
guérilleros ce annonce à clara roja ce
qu'ils vont la libérer mais elle refuse
d'abandonner ingrid betancourt dans les
profondeurs de la jungle amazonienne
pendant cinq mois plus aucun signe de
vie jusqu'à cette vidéo où elle apparaît
silencieuse au côté d'ingrid betancourt
un an plus tard les farc on voit une
autre vidéo où elle s'adresse avec une
ironie mordante à sa mère je suis dans
la jungle colombienne dans un endroit
paradisiaque en avril 2007 à l'ancienne
otage des farc franck pin chao confirme
une information que beaucoup pensaient
invraisemblable clara rojas a bien eu un
enfant avec l'un de ses geôliers
il révèle le prénom emmanuel il a trois
ans et sa grand mère rêve de découvrir
enfin les traits de son visage que une
fiction depuis que j'ai appris son
existence
je veux le tenir dans mes bras grâce à
des tons blancs et s'est occupée elle
avait quelqu'un à qui donner de l'amour
aux yeux de l'amour et la tendresse d'un
bébé élevé par les guérilleros ce
l'enfant doit également être remis en
liberté au côté de sa mère et de
consuelo gonzalez
une parlementaire colombienne enlevée le
10 septembre 2001 mélanie bettencourt
bonsoir vous connaissez clara rojas
l'ami de votre mère
est-ce que ce à quoi on assiste ce soir
vous fait dire que c'est encore un faux
espoir ou au contraire vous avez le
sentiment que ce soir quelque chose se
passe et que ça bouge vraiment non je
pense que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est extrêmement important quand on verra
le visage de kara d'emmanuel le compte
soit le camp ils seront enfin libres
après toutes ces années et bien
définitivement les farc vous fait un
geste unilatéral de bonne volonté cela
prouvera et bien que les choses peuvent
avancer qu'on peut négocier avec eux et
à ce moment là non ça sera vraiment
autour du président que l'on vient et
bien de prendre la décision lucide de
faire un pas en avant pour pour un
accord humanitaire
il n'y a pas un risque aussi que les
farc cette fois ci est fait plaisir
entre guinéens au goût de chavez le
président vénézuélien mais qu'ensuite
ils reviennent avec leurs revendications
que le président colombien n'a jamais
accepté je pense que mon ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que la médiation du président hugo
chavez apporté de très beaux fruits vous
l'aviez dit dès le départ d'ailleurs et
j'ai je pense que voilà aujourd'hui le
président colombien a été forcé de
reconnaître et sera forcé de reconnaître
si la libération a bien lieu ce soir ou
demain je l'espère que que hugo chavez
s'est complètement habilités à faire
avancer du chenal déclarent qu'ils
continuent selon il faudrait qu'ils
continuent alors après ce sera au
président colombien soit d'accepter et
de d'essayer de faire que les conditions
que demandent les farc puisse être
acceptable par lui aussi et ça c'est des
choses qui peuvent se faire il le sait
très bien soin de faire que la médiation
d'hugo chavez continue et que ce soit au
coach aziz lui-même qui a dialogué avec
le commandant malo l'inde a que me l'a
demandé
si clara rusk et comme on l'espère
libéré dans les heures qui viennent
j'imagine que vous allez allez l'avoir
pour qu'elle vous parle de votre mère
déjà je vais d'abord la leaf et
retrouver sa famille ça fait six ans
qu'il n'a pas vu sa mère et ses proches
mais c'est vrai que voilà sa libération
et celle d'emmanuel et celle de consuelo
est le plus beau cadeau que vous pouvez
offrir à leurs familles et maintenant il
faut que ce soit un élan quand elle se
fera cette libération pour que tous les
autres toutes les autres familles
puissent aussi retrouvé les leurs il
faut que maman et tous les autres otages
reviennent aussi donc c'est une
impulsion cette libération au 6 mai
pour être d'être venu nous apporter ce
témoignage et puis bon courage et à très
bientôt pour des bonnes nouvelles on
espère merci on va retrouver maintenant
en direct du venezuela renaud bernard
qui est donc à caracas où les opérations
sont coordonnées avec les dernières
informations renault dont vous disposez
écoutez il ya un signe c'est la sérénité
des familles des trois otages qui se
trouve 6,6 à caracas les farc comptant
pas donné signe de vie ont fixé rendez
vous à l'opération et elles ont même
donné une exigence des hélicoptères plus
petits qui pourront se poser dans une
clairière particulière dans la jungle
c'est donc que tout est en bonne voie et
cette sérénité est d'autant plus
admirable qu'on ne sait pas quand
exactement
les trois otages seront libérés et qu'on
ne connaît pas l'état de santé de clara
rojas du petit emmanuel et de la
parlementaire compte selon gonzalez les
familles ont été rassurés ce matin par
les affirmations du gouvernement
colombien qui a annoncé deux choses la
première il n'y a plus de limite de
temps à la réalisation de cette
opération de sauvetage et l'armée
colombienne n'attaquera pas les farc
tant que les trois otages ne seront pas
sortis de la jungle merci au no voilà ce
que l'on pouvait dire sur cette
actualité bien sûr nous y reviendrons
dans ce journal si jamais elle évolue
entre temps dans le reste de l'actualité
en attendant à l'étranger une image
d'abord un visage plus exactement celui
du successeur de benazir buttho c'est
son fils qui a été désigné pour prendre
la tête du parti du peuple pakistanais
il s'appelle bilawal il n'a que 19 ans
son père a quant à lui été nommé
co-président les deux assureront donc
ensemble la relève politique de la
dynastie familiale et je vous rappelle
que le parti avait été fondée par le
grand père lui même exécuté en 79 alors
le clan bhutto a donc décidé de réagir
rapidement pour assurer la continuité de
son combat politique
mais les cicatrices ouverte par
l'assassinât de benazir mettront elles
beaucoup de temps avant de se refermer
et nous avons pu nous rendre aujourd'hui
à l'endroit où l'attentât a été commis
dans la banlieue d'islamabad envoyés
spéciaux philippe rochot tristan le
brasse c'est devenu un nouveau lieu de
pélérinage là où est tombé benazir butto
ses partisans se relaie pour honorer sa
mémoire son dernier meeting était un
défi car c'est là qu'a déjà été
assassiné un premier ministre
pakistanais licka d'al hira en 1950
c'est aussi à rawalpindi que le père de
benazir a été pendu elle se croyait
protégé parce que cette ville est la
place forte de l'armée pakistanaise il
n'en était rien il n'y a pas la moindre
sécurité ici l'armée n'a absolument rien
fait pas protéger benazir butto et c'est
pour cela qu'ils ont pu tirer sur l 100
m dans les rues des rawalpindi tout
semblait pourtant en place pour une
victoire de l'opposition au président
musharraf des affiches partout c'est
comme si on allait voter demain
cet assassinat de benazir vient
d'anéantir l'opposition pour un temps
mais au pc de benazir buttho les femmes
du parti populaire sont prêtes à relever
le défi
nous sommes fiers de notre parti et de
ses chefs car sous le même parapluie
il y à des religieuses les femmes et une
sorte de gens ce qui représente le
peuple
après trois jours de deuil national les
magasins devraient rouvrir demain
né à rawalpindi et toutes les villes du
pakistan vont rester sous haute
surveillance dans la province du sind
seize mille forces paramilitaires sont
en position pour empêcher de nouvelles
émeutes qui aurait fait une quarantaine
de morts en trois jours
ce soir encore autour de l'hôpital ou
benazir buttho a rendu son dernier
soupir
des petits groupes de manifestants
venaient montrer leur colère et leur
douleur
une partie du pakistan demeure
inconsolable et en direct d'islamabad on
retrouve philippe rochot philippe le
fils de benazir buttho on l'a dit a
repris le flambeau ce soir comment
est-ce que cela était perçue chez les
partisans chez qui vous êtes
écoutez très bien puisque l'essentiel
pour eux c'était que le successeur de
madame butô et du sang buteau dans les
veines et précisément comme c'est son
fils il correspond tout à fait aux
espoirs que la population a placée en
lui
simplement on sait très bien que il est
hésitant il est très hésitant à prendre
les rênes de ce parti et que c'est donc
son père qui dans un premier temps on va
le faire et on peut comprendre ses
hésitations quand on voit à quoi cela
mène ici au pakistan de prendre les
directions d'un tel parti alors le parti
du peuple pakistanais a décidé tout à
l'heure qu'ils participeraient bien aux
élections législatives le 8 janvier
l'autre principal opposant a adopté la
même ligne est ce que ça veut dire que
ces élections auront bien lieu comme
prévu ecoutez-la la commission
électorale va se réunir demain pour
décider si oui ou non les élections
peuvent avoir lieu le 8 janvier ou s'il
convient de les reporter on parle d'un
délai de 60 jours qui correspondrait au
deuil national et puis aussi jusqu'à
trois mois pour pour lancer cette
campagne électorale qui aurait donc lieu
simplement où pas de
au mois de mars mais donc la commission
électorale va se réunir demain en tout
cas l'important c'est que le parti
populaire accepte finalement de
participer à ces élections et que
derrière le parti de nawaz sharif suis
également ses directives et donc les
formations politiques seront vraiment
représentée dans ces élections a que ce
sont des élections qui seront équilibrés
en quelque sorte
merci philippe étions là après tout à
l'heure nicolas sarkozy a proposé au
président pakistanais du envoyé son
ministre des affaires étrangères pour
témoigner de sa solidarité
bernard kouchner se rendra donc au
pakistan dans les 48 heures nicolas
sarkozy qui a quitté le jeans pour
remettre son costume présidentiel
aujourd'hui son séjour privé en egypte
s'est transformé depuis ce matin en
visite officielle la première pour le
président français dans un pays du
proche orient
autant dire que ses déclarations sur les
relations entre la france et le monde
arabe était très attendu envoyés
spéciaux charles enderlin le rang des
boires
finies les vacances journée chargée pour
le président sarkozy rencontre
officielle avec son homologue égyptien
hosni moubarak
les deux hommes ont poursuivi leur
entretien commencé il ya quelques jours
à sharm el cheikh sur le liban et le
rôle de la syrie
ils sont d'accord je ne prendrai plus de
contacts avec les syriens
tant que nous n'aurons pas des preuves
de la volonté des syriens de laisser le
liban désigner un président de consensus
pour mesurer je demande à la syrie
d'utiliser ses pouvoirs pour aider le
parlement libanais à élire un président
les relations franco égyptienne vont
bien symbole nicolas sarkozy a déposé
une gerbe sur la tombe d'anouar el
sadate le premier président arabe à
signer la paix avec israël oubliez les
grincements de dents de certains milieux
fassent aux prises de positions
pro-israéliennes de monsieur sarkozy est
une base importante la france aide les
pays arabes est positif cette visite
prouve que la sécurité règne en egypte
et puis c'est très bon pour le tourisme
du caire nicolas sarkozy a lancé un
appel à israël pour qu'il fasse des
gestes qui permettraient de prouver que
la paix est possible
être un ami fidèle at il dit ce n'est
pas être un ami complaisant et la visite
officielle n'empêche pas quelques
petites escapades touristiques en cours
de journée le président a fait un saut
sur le plateau de gizeh pour visiter la
grande pyramide avec sa compagne carla
bruni l'ex top model vous le voyez a
même pensé à l'appareil photo
probablement n'était ce pas la peine vu
le nombre de paparazzi qui gravitaient
autour du couple nicolas sarkozy qui
rentrera dès demain en france veut
présidentielle oblige
comme le veut la tradition vous pourrez
donc les suivre à la télévision même si
à l'elysée on assure qu'il y aura aussi
de la rupture dans cet exercice à leur
rupture par rapport à quoi
alexandre kara s'est replongé dans les
archives de la vème république
vous allez voir que ça ne manque pas de
piment
cinq présidents cinq styles c'est avec
le général de gaulle que pour la
première fois les caméras de télévision
entre à l'elysée un 31 décembre
françaises français je vous souhaite une
bonne année et il la république et la
prend feu devait se posant de la
république première début des années
soixante dix avec georges pompidou
le style est tout aussi solennel mais le
ton plus détendu
françaises français voici le nouvel an
avec valéry giscard d'estaing l'exercice
pour un coup de jeune
chaque année la mise en scène est
soigneusement étudié un style très
président de proximité quand vous parlez
surtout son devoir on peut préparer sur
l'apport plus fort à la mairie certains
bidonvilles
il est naturel que je vous adresse mes
voeux parce que pendant l'année dans
l'exercice de mes fonctions je pense à
vous 1981 le changement mais pas pour
les boues françois mitterrand revient
une forme très présidentiel seule
l'histoire pourra dire avec le recul du
temps la trace laissée par l'année qui
s'achève
mais chacun sait déjà que 1981 aura été
l'année du changement que la france a
voulu
treize ans plus tard affaibli par la
maladie ses voeux prennent des accents
de tester brown
azo force de l'esprit et je ne vous
quitterai pas une forme ce soir des
voeux pour vous tous à chacun de ses
voeux jacques chirac lui garde des
accents de campagne
je refuse la fracture sociale
apparu au fil des ans les moments où un
peuple se rassemblent respire au même
rythme bas d'un même coeur sont toujours
des moments privilégiés que c'est demain
nicolas sarkozy tentera à son tour
d'imprimer sa marque à cet exercice
présidentielle oblige est alors bien
souvent à l'occasion des voeux on
souhaite la santé bien sûr mais aussi
les sous le pouvoir d'achat comme on dit
aujourd'hui le président devrait en
parler demain soir d'autant qu'il a
promis l'année prochaine la possibilité
de racheter les rtt
comment est-ce que cela va marcher à
partir de quand et qui sera concerné
exactement vois ça avec sophie brune et
philippe dias la principale mesure de la
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat le rachat des
rtt
le principe est simple plutôt que de
poser ses jours de récupération se les
faire payer
sont concernés les rtt non prise au 31
décembre et celles qui seront accumulés
jusqu'au 30 juin de l'an prochain s'il
n'y a pas d'accord collectif dans
l'entreprise le salarié est censé
pouvoir négocier directement avec son
employeur mais celui ci n'a aucune
obligation
combien séjour seront ils payés pour
l'air s'était accumulée en 2007 elles
seront majorées d'au moins 10% est
exonérée de charges sociales sauf csg
et la crds pour les rtt 2008 le système
est plus avantageux car il est calqué
sur le dispositif des heures
supplémentaires elles seront majorées de
25 %
exonérée de charges sociales et ne
seront pas soumises à l'impôt sur le
revenu censé doper le pouvoir d'achat
cette mesure ne pourra concerner qu'une
minorité de français un peu plus du
tiers des salariés disposent de rtt
la loi instaure aussi la possibilité de
débloquer de façon anticipée les fonds
de participation
si le salarié le souhaitent autre moyen
d'augmenter son pouvoir d'achat c'est en
tout cas ce que pensent les
boursicoteurs le cac40 autrement dit les
quarante plus grosses valeurs françaises
à la bourse
cet indice s'apprête à fêter demain ses
20 ans d'existence c'est ce qui est sûr
c'est que même s'il ya eu des hauts et
des bas à long terme il reste
probablement le placement le plus sûr
pour un investisseur en main mais si peu
et cambrai c'était l'époque des derniers
sons de cloches les dernières heures de
la criée à la corbeille du palais
brongniart 31 décembre 1987 à la bourse
un nouvel indice voit le jour le cac40
mesuré sur les quarante plus grosses
sociétés françaises
vingt ans plus tard les ordinateurs ont
remplacé la criée mais le cac40 s'est
imposé comme un indice boursier mondial
à la fois référence et baromètre de
l'économie française il est passé de
1000 points à ses débuts à 5600 points
aujourd'hui on retrouve maintenant comme
dans la forme du cac
tous les grands événements qui sont
arrivés dans le monde il est parti de là
le cac où vous devez arriver là mais je
dis à ce qu'il va pas une droite des
hauts et des bas il y a eu des crises
financières dans les années 90 mais
aussi des envolées spectaculaires comme
la fameuse bulle internet
en septembre 2000 le cac 40 est à son
plus haut avant de s'effondrer tout ce
qui était nouvelle économie
technologique montait fortement
et donc leur poids augmenter l'indicé
donc l' indice cette époque là aussi on
comprend 99
le cac 40 a démonté 50% ce qui est
énorme pour un indice un indice trop
soumis aux effets de mode pour certains
financiers le symbole d'une économie
irrationnel pour d'autres mais en vingt
ans le cac 40 a connu une croissance
globale de 560 % pour les actionnaires
présents depuis les débuts le meilleur
des placements financiers ont parlé de
pouvoir d'achat tout à l'heure la france
n'est pas la seule à avoir souffert du
passage à l'euro
les slovènes qui ont adopté début 2007
la monnaie unique en sont déjà
officiellement à une inflation de 6 %
il faut dire que ce petit pays de
l'ex-yougoslavie entrée dans l'union il
ya quatre ans déjà attire
particulièrement les investisseurs dans
la vie il semble agréable et l'économie
florissante
jérôme germain christan l'euro reportage
si la france et la slovénie n'avait
qu'un point commun ce serait celui-ci la
passion du vin ou rochereau jacques et
viticulteur à 29 ans il possède une
petite exploitation d'une dizaine
d'hectares
après des études à l'étranger il a
préféré revenir dans son pays pour y
produire son orgueil notre ville entrée
dans l'union européenne les exportations
vont bien mais nous faisons ici un vin
de qualité les trois quarts de la
production sont à destination de l'union
la slovénie a toujours été tournés vers
l'europe logique vu la situation
géographique de ce petit pays de deux
millions d'habitants grand comme trois
départements français
voici lubiana la capitale ne vous fiez
pas à son architecture austro-hongroise
la slovénie change vite seul état de
l'ex yougoslavie à ne pas avoir connu la
guerre économie performante 6 % de
croissance annuelle
une main d'oeuvre très qualifiée bon
marché renault ne s'y est pas trompé sa
twingo
c'est ici que la firme l'a fait
construire ses qualités des slovènes
c'est d'être réac easter et ça ce sont
les qualités que nous avons dans l'
usine et ce sont des qualités qui vient
aussi en slovénie c'est que les chances
vont très vite très vite en effet la
slovénie intègre l'union européenne en
2004 et passe à l'euro il ya tout juste
un an
pas de quoi troubler la légendaire
quiétude et slovènes il ya de plus en
plus de touristes
mais ce qui a surtout changé ce sont les
prix ils augmentent sans cesse depuis
l'introduction de l'euro
la valse des étiquettes un peu refroidi
les slovènes 6 % d'inflation en inde en
officiellement alors que les salaires
stagnent 800 euros en moyenne mais le
rythme de vie restent très attractifs
les européens s'y précipitent pour
investir dans les montagnes surtout ils
ont acheté 70 % des propriétés l'an
dernier la plupart sont britanniques
comme ce couple ça vous change du stress
londonien ah oui définitivement
l'autre jour j'ai vu à la télé les
courses de noël à londres et non merci
et adieu les milliardaires russes le
métro et tout le reste
enfant chéri liste avec ses
investissements étrangers de plus en
plus important
la slovénie a de beaux jours devant elle
parmi les derniers entrants au sein de
l'union européenne la slovénie fait
figure de très bon élève son pib par
habitant est déjà supérieur à celui du
portugal ou de la grèce
c'est sans doute parce que les slovènes
étaient européens bien avant l'heure et
la slovénie qui prendra donc la
présidence de l'union européenne pour
six mois à partir du 1er janvier 2008
c'est à dire après demain si je vous dis
il ne vous reste que deux jours vous
avez bien compris à qui je m'adresse
mesdames messieurs les fumeurs ruez-vous
dans les cafés jetez-vous dans les
restaurants car après demain soir ce
sera terminé pour s'en griller une dans
un établissement quel qu'il soit vous le
savez tous mais êtes vous vraiment prêt
diane benzina frédéric basket une
dernière bouffée
enfin une des dernières comme tous les
autres celui seront parisien sur un an
fumeurs ici 80% des qui enfume mais un
espace fumeur ça coûte trop cher du coup
le patron est bien décidé à faire
appliquer la loi
brochures à l'appui comment parler aux
gens qui fument de l'équipe qu'il ne
faut pas fumer
le serveur est fumeur et moi aussi
ils vont par tient sur plus tôt le soir
au lieu de rester à boire l'apéro au
comptoir et les habitués grogne un peu
mais dans la salle on trouve ça plutôt
bien
c'est quand même agréable parce qu'ils
sont complètement sûrs d'eux au ciel
justement dans la même rue à deux portes
de là on a banni la cigarette depuis
plusieurs années tout le restaurant et
non fumeurs et les affaires marchent
bien quand ils ont envie de jouer ils
vont dehors il fut douce et garrett ils
reviennent et on continue le service on
est vraiment impatient que ça passe
partout comme ça
partout pareil alors certains ont pris
les devants ce café est non fumeur
depuis un mois objectif faciliter la
transition
non il est serein d'être au niveau des
amendes tout ça on a déjà un mois
d'avant donc on sera plus vigilant ça
nous avons permettra peut-être d'éviter
des amendes tout bête que on aura les
reflex dont je vois les gens qui fument
ou de leur si on est étonné parce que
marquer 1er décembre donc on s'est dit
on s'entraide date est en fait le monde
on s'est dit que c'était une très bonne
idée de d'habituer les gens avant la
date la date prévue et pour ceux qui ont
du mal à s'y faire est la cigarette sera
toléré jusqu'à mercredi
ensuite il faudra aller chercher les
sangliers à l'extérieur en cette fin
d'année il y a deux incontournables ce
sont les voeux on en a parlé et puis les
étrennes alors la tradition remonte aux
romains qui donnait à cette époque des
dates et du miel mais nous vous
déconseillons d'en faire de même
aujourd'hui
pas sûr que les pompiers les facteurs ou
les concierges apprécié aurélia bros
dominique bonnet à gauche du sapin dans
le miroir
c'est madame valente la gardienne de
l'immeuble et en cette période de
l'année madame valent entre reçoit ses
étrennes selon usage cela représente 10%
du loyer de chaque habitant pour
distribuer le courrier mais aussi
arroser les plantes ou nourrir les chats
ici la gardienne rend beaucoup de
services alors un noël
alors tous ceux qui sont là il me donne
quelque chose pour noël oui y'a pas un
rat dans ma loge pas de radin mais
combien de cello jusque chez vous en
fait c'est pas vraiment moi qui donne à
mon mari qui prend pas avant que je
crois que ça représentait 50 ans je n'ai
pas la force du monde mais je donne ce
qu'il faut donner je crois en fait selon
les années madame valente peut espérer
l'équivalent d'un mois de salaire
pas sûr que tous les gardiens
d'immeubles soit logé à la même enseigne
un rapide tour sur les champs-elysées
suffit à s'en convaincre
mais combien votre concierge en féraud
on dit que c'est 10% du loyer césar va
non seulement pas on donne pas tout à
fait dispensable nous donne quand même
1150 euros et la tradition concerne
aussi les facteurs pour qui il est
d'usagé de donner 5 euros en échange de
leur calendrier des calendriers les
pompiers en distribuer eux aussi mais
les 5 à 10 euros que vous leur donnerez
iront directement dans les caisses
d'associations de soutien aux familles
des pompiers
et si vous ne voulez pas passer pour un
radin il vous reste jusqu'à fin janvier
pour offrir vos étrennes mourir à 35 ans
ce n'est déjà pas naturel mais mourir à
cet âge sur un stade alors qu on est
sportif de haut niveau ça l'est
probablement encore moins
hier le capitaine d'une équipe de
football britannique s'est écroulé à la
fin d'une rencontre il n'avait pourtant
pas de problèmes cardiaques
c'est le deuxième décès de ce type en
quatre mois le septième en quatre ans
arnaud ursule à 35 ans phil o'donnell
n'avait plus rien à prouver sur un
terrain de football
en juin dernier le milieu de terrain
écossais avait annoncé qu'il mettrait un
terme à sa carrière à la fin de cette
saison
ce matin l'émotion est vive devant le
stade de motherwell son club de toujours
o'donnell ll avait fait ses débuts en
1990 à tout juste 17 ans entraîneurs
dirigeants joueurs fans
tout le monde est sous le choc on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'est passé
apparemment fils a fait un malaise il a
été déclaré mort en fin d'après-midi à
sa routine était le nom de phil
o'donnell s'ajoute à la triste liste des
joueurs mort sur un terrain de football
le 28 août dernier à séville
le défenseur espagnol antonio puerta
s'effondre sur la pelouse victime de
quatre arrêts cardiaques
l'international ibérique 17 trois jours
plus tard à l'hôpital
il avait 22 ans origine du décès une
malformation cardiaque
une hypertrophie du coeur qui quatre ans
plus tôt à lyon emporté le camerounais
marc vivien foé
point commun entre ces trois
footballeurs on ne leur connaissait
aucun problème vasculaire ou cardiaques
dans ces conditions le nouveau drame
d'hier pourrait bien relancer la
polémique sur le suivi médical des
joueurs des larmes et de la joie aussi
il y en a eu cette année dans le sport
dans 28 heures maintenant 2007 s'achève
on retiendra de belles réussites
individuelles et puis quelques échecs
collectifs des bleus sur le terrain des
bleus aussi à la met au coeur
christophe duchiron alors que 2007 et
pratiquement dans le rétroviseur les son
défilé une année de sport tricolore est
contrasté
avant de finir comme chacun sait sur
internet laure manaudou a commencé
l'année en beauté
à l'époque deux championnats du monde
elle goûtait aux amours transalpine et
remporté deux médailles d'or sur 200 et
400 m après vint le temps des ruptures
elle avait quitté son entraîneur
philippe lucas et la france pour
s'entraîner en italie qu'elle ne
tarderait pas à quitter aussi saison de
natation confondues en roman feuilleton
par la championne pipoliser il y eut
peut être cette année au fond des yeux
de laure un peu plus que du club
la voiture de sébastien loeb fait moins
de bruit que les aventures de laure
manaudou mais le pilote de rallye est
plus discret néanmoins il est champion
du monde pour la quatrième année
consécutive
en face
où es tu
deux mètres 0 3 127 kg champion du monde
de judo à 18 ans teddy riner est une
montagne de talent précoce
monsieur propre février les carrelages
et tony parker les parquets pour la
troisième fois le champion de nba avec
san antonio est aussi meilleur joueur de
la finale la france du patin aura
attendu quarante deux ans et brian
joubert champion du monde au japon pour
la première fois de sa carrière
partout petite mini gueule de bois
un soir d'octobre et d'illusions perdues
en coupe du monde de rugby ou français
la chabalmania et au sud africain le
titre de champion du monde confiance de
france les ambitions trop grande à
bernard laporte le secrétariat d'état
aux sports
mieux que rien mais moins bien que prévu
une cinquième place au championnat du
monde de hand
néanmoins les filles sont qualifiés pour
les jo contrairement aux basketteurs
éliminé le grand déballage de la grande
boucle
quel programme des mensonges des
suspicions des transfusions des
tricheurs des exclusions de mauvais
procès en avis divers et avariés
cacophonique et catastrophique tour de
france 2007
à part ça aussi sûr que l'hiver arrive
après l'automne lyon est encore champion
de france de foot est aussi vrai que le
psg est toujours à la traîne après
demain nous sommes en 2008 cinéma c'est
peut-être l'un des premiers films que
vous pourrez aller voir l'année
prochaine dès mercredi
le dernier film de ken loach sort en
salles c'est un monde libre c'est son
titre
un film qui dénonce l'exploitation en
grande bretagne des immigrés venus des
pays de l'est
marie-jo juin olivier robert après des
années de galère en jean à monter avec
son amie rose une agence d'intérim les
milliers d'ouvriers immigrés de londres
peuvent devenir une bonne source de
revenus mais voilà la jeune femme et son
ami dans un monde de machos vont devoir
vendre leur âme au diable
si j'avais montré quelqu'un d'
antipathique qui exploite les gens et
carlos place était prévisible en prenant
quelques uns comme angie à qui on
s'attache qui est elle même une victime
sont des fans et qu'on la voit peu à se
faire des choses mauvaises terrible une
vicieuse mais là c'est vraiment efficace
dans ma propre famille vient d'un
jamaïque
ils sont arrivés également vous avez
plein d'espoir mais le problème c'est
qu'en fait leurs attentes ont été
réduites à néant
mais avec des conditions de travail
déplorables de logements encore pire
quand je sais tout ça je connais bien
j'espère que ce film va toucher les gens
nous même si c'est une minorité
pour que les choses changent jeudi même
si un film les changes rares mots tout
ce que je souhaite est que les ouvriers
comme ceux venus de l'est ne soient plus
considérés comme des moins que rien
parce que tout le monde les voit comme
ça
une fois de plus ken loach grand
défenseur de la classe ouvrière frappe
fort sont angie devenu ange
exterminateur fait froid dans le dos on
va terminer en musique avec l'un des
plus grands maestros du moment où
devrais même dire maestra puisque c'est
une femme même si le mot n'existe pas en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
valérie aymen sa baguette avec maestria
elle est en ce moment en concert à
travers l'europe christophe airaud
didier da
partons en voyage avec un chef non
plutôt une chaleur emmanuelle haïm
envie
sous sa direction et sans baguette ils
sont soixante musiciens des chanteurs
son répertoire le baron et sa méthode
un or qu'est-ce que c'est une équipe
c'est pas si c'est la partie je veux
presser mais par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a l'occasion de se voir se
parler de t'avoir un peu de temps
ensemble
c'est par un ordre à coeur il ya
énormément de monde qu'elle n'a pas
toujours le temps du pouvoir rencontrer
les uns et les autres
vous la regardez diriger et vous
comprenez ce qu'elle donne et demande
alors qu'istres
pour justifier prima la musica comme on
dit
c'est dire au centre la musique et
surtout
dans tout musique elle retrouvait les
être le moyen de raconter une histoire
d'inventer une trame adrar
je suis très sensible à la voix chantée
et où fait que quelqu'un puisse à la
fois faire la musique et raconter un
texte est c'est fait c'est quelque chose
qui me touche très directement
répétition à son domicile parisien
ce soir la cantate de bach avec
métallique dos et qui ne jurent que par
elle elle a une façon de faire de la
musique qui me correspond exactement
c'est à dire c'est à la fois extrêmement
sensuelle très passionné très dramatique
c'est comme ma soeur c'est comme un
terreau ego en chef d'orchestre quoi
ce soir là c'était une belle et bac dans
l'église le camp il durera mou et
monteverdi bientôt lully je ne sais pas
comment on le dit au féminin mais
emmanuelle haïm est vraiment
là il s'agit bien d'emmanuelle haïm fin
de ce journal je le rappelle le
principal titre il ya quelques heures
deux nouveaux hélicoptères ont atterri à
villavicencio en colombie des
hélicoptères plus petit que ce qui avait
été prévu pour aller chercher les otages
dans la jungle
apparemment les organisateurs de la
mission humanitaire dispose désormais
d'informations précises notamment sur le
lieu où ils doivent récupérer ces otages
cela dit on apprend à l'instant que
l'opération vient d'être à nouveau
reporté on ne dispose pas de date mais
tout le monde espère que cela pourra se
faire demain c'est tout pour l'actualité
de ce dimanche dans un instant vous dira
si le temps sera clément pour la
dernière journée de l'année ce sera la
météo avec isabelle martinet à 20h50
rires garantis avec celui que personne
ne voudrait avoir comme ami je vous avez
rendez vous avec michel blanc et gérard
lanvin pour marche à l'ombre pour
l'information demain vous retrouverez
françoise laborde à 13h david pujadas à
20h et puis pour ma part et bien on se
retrouvera l'année prochaine je vous la
souhaite donc bonne et heureuse
excellente soirée sur france 2
que nous dit
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
votre